we mentioned that New York City has its
first case of the corona virus it is a
woman in her 30s who recently returned
from Iran and who is now in isolation
New York's Governor Andrew Cuomo joins
us with more on this story governor good
morning to you you know a lot of New
Yorkers welcome a lot of New Yorkers
certainly here in the city woke up and
said oh no here we go what can you tell
us about this latest case what do we
know yeah well good morning to all of
you a new girl first New Yorkers should
not be surprised we've been talking
about this for days I said it's not a
question of if but when you see the
number of cases around the globe New
York is the gateway to the world so
that's not shocking and we've been
preparing for it and we've been truly
diligent on this issue this is somewhat
of a unique case because this woman was
a health care worker coming back from
Iran as you mentioned so she knew to
take precautions and stay in a
controlled situation and then go for
testing and we got the testing results
back so I don't think there's anything
extraordinary in this case of anything
because she was a health care worker she
knew to take precautions herself which
was fortunate governor how effective do
you expect that test to be and do you
have enough will you have enough well
good question we just got the federal
authority to do the testing and we are
now going to scale up very very quickly
so we'll have the ability to test and
again in this quote-unquote containment
phase it's about the detection and then
the isolation and it's the mobilization
of the healthcare system more than
anything beyond that it's a
communication issue to people you know
there's we we want to keep this we want
to have a healthy
diligence about this issue but we don't
want an unnecessary anxiety and we don't
want people overreacting so it's that's
what this is really about to me can you
confirm that she was she lives in
Manhattan and if that is the case
have you ruled out the possibility of
something like we saw in China where a
city or a region is sealed off as a
containment method yeah she does live in
Manhattan
she is isolated in her apartment and
there's no cause to do anything but that
again this is not by the Ebola was much
more frightening than this issue we've
gone through viruses that are frankly
more frightening than this so we need
little context for all of this a little
perspective we have to treat it we have
to be serious but there's the the fear
in my opinion is outpacing reason at
this place at this point
governor we thank we thank you very much
for your time thanks very much governor
thanks guys thank you